let's bring back Larry Fitzgerald I the
better yes yes where are you today by
heart I'm how many apples get just got
done training and uh you know this is
just hanging out with you know how do
you know when you've had a good workout
uh I go through shirts use usually I'm
ha um I'm usually knowing I'm put in the
work putting the time we not try to do
everything I can to mimic you know a
practice attorney can practice in terms
of the volume of running that I'm doing
every single day and follow the topic
etching so I just try to make sure that
I'm you know giving it what I what I
have and still doing what I've always
done just to get ready for this year
when do you feel old you know honestly I
don't feel old i mean if if i did not
know how old I was you know I don't
think I will be able to tell the
difference between you know when I first
came into Lee and now you know I've done
a great job of you know can continue to
stay take care of my body putting the
right things in my system you know i'm
just getting rest i think that's
something that i think as you don't take
for granted but obviously with the EAS
sports nutrition that you're calling us
on behalf that that's helped you but at
what point did you embrace nutrition you
know i think around 25 26 others are
being a lot more of the kind of fool jan
i was eating and always you know no took
my my pledge shakes and you know did
that in terms it is not making bad
decisions you know when you have kids
like so for other people you know
there's lots of snacks always around the
house and you sitting around the house
and the kids are sleeping and you
messing around and going there even
golden grahams and you know all the
stuff you don't do that anymore you know
i got a chef now to prepare my meals and
you know I just make a lot better
decisions in that regard any good travel
in the offseason yeah we went to went
over to London for a little bit of
Wimbledon action was in was in France
and then Congo you know stop in a couple
different places congo yeah i was over
there for humanitarian mission with
turkey hair and foundation nice for a
few days
with the campaign Mutombo so it was fun
had a great time did you get recognized
anybody have fitzgerald jersey on no no
no I saw one guy with a Hines Ward
Jersey on I don't even think I don't
even I don't even think he knew highs or
what are you at a big tennis guy or you
just want to do experience Wimbledon no
I love I love tennis i've been i've been
the minimum belen been to rolling Gary's
watch the French Open been australian
open wow you could usually go to indian
wells I love tennis is so graceful you
know with watching Roger Federer and you
know the doll and Novak and obviously
Serena and it's a lot of fun to see the
skill how would you do if you let let's
say Serena said let's let's play set
here Larry uh she would she would she
would give the main story sets it would
be close yeah I you know I think I think
if I got into a good you know rally I'll
be able to hold up with returning to
serve is is impossible you know when a
serves coming 100 100 15 and 20
mile-an-hour Bella not just put the
record on it but actually you know hit
it with some substance is a little
difficult who throws the hardest
football you've ever cut the hardest
most people Derek Anderson Derek Derek
Anderson has a has a rocket are it is it
though the ball a lot of velocity is it
hurt no it doesn't hurt but it you know
it is coming with some steam I help me
with this quote that you're gonna kick
you want to continue to play as long as
Carson Palmer's your quarterback and I
am I being fair to the quote there that
it's basically I I want to play and not
have any drama at that position as long
as we have carson i want to continue to
play yeah you know you know how you have
a good producer i work and it just it
works for you you know what I mean like
he knows what she likes you know he you
know what expect every day that that's
kind of the same phenazine relationship
I have a Carson I've gone through the
quarter bag carousel you know for a lot
of time my career and and I have is a
great rapport with Carson you know I'm
not interested in you know happen to
deal with any more
anon stability at the position Carson's
climate elite level and it makes not
only my job with the rest of our jobs
much easier how do those young db's help
you I mean how much contact you know as
far as helping you with routes so
Patrick Peterson or honey badger how
much do they help you on a daily basis
always great going against my majors
doesn't I don't think there's too many
guys that are better than those two
players you know in the National
Football League and be able to have
ability to go up against them every
single day like I go up against tie
every day in the slot and when I'm
outside you know pets on me and you know
you have to be at your best to beat
those guys and it not only for me but
for Michael Floyd and John Brown and say
Jay Nelson I mean you're getting the
best of the best and you know so what
we're competing against other teams you
know it's it's like you know we've
already gone against the best players in
the business and we should be able to go
out here and dominate these guys talk to
you the opposition these defensive backs
or they have enough respect for you that
they leave you alone yeah I don't know
if this is respect bodies I just don't
talk myself you know unless it's I think
they want to talk normal then you know I
might have a little bit of dialogue but
I'm out there talking I'm out there to
play and do my job and I'd help my team
when you know a lot of guys like to talk
you know to cover up you know some
insecurities no no I don't like to feel
all that but if anybody ever just had a
normal conversation with you on the
football field where it's just like hey
Larry how are you album yeah all the
time all the time first is you know I
know guy like you know peanut tillman
god I played against countless times no
playing in between plays will but talk
about whatever but you know when it went
between the whistles and when it's time
to play and were competing like I don't
know them but you know you have a lot of
mutual respect for guys like that who
have been around the game for a long
long time and played um you know that at
a good clip he's Larry Fitzgerald
joining us on behalf of EA sports
nutrition where can people EIS sports
nutrition where can people find out more
about that layer where they can go on
yes column on the website also in other
twitter handles atias brand
you know they are there also on Facebook
for any information and that they would
like to learn about EAS last time you
thought about this super bowl I think
about her every single day you know got
so close last year play play terribly
you know at the very worst time as you
go faster play but I don't think it
diminishes what we able to accomplish
last year even we're flexible anization
you know been around a long long time
man you know to be like Oh 33 was a
great you know start and we pretty much
have the same nucleus of guys coming
back actually it have added some pieces
the great pass-rusher on Chandler Jones
rafting Robin indicis know helped us
tremendously really gonna get better you
think back to the steeler lost the Super
Bowl yeah I made it it does it does
always you know you know leave a bad
taste in your mouth and especially I was
with Santonio Holmes this weekend an
event and I just only made it worse so
did he bring it up have another comment
no I'm people this is how their happened
to ring on his finger you know worse you
know you see that like damn I could I
could have been on my finger I could
have been a lot better would you wear it
every day if you had a Super Bowl ring
no I never I never wear I never wear you
know I first like one NFC championship
ring I've never I've never put it on my
finger it's just I'm not wondering guys
that walks around and wants to have a
conversation about it's one of those
things that I just will probably put in
my safe and you know somebody wanted to
see it I'll show it's on but I would
walk around with it Jerry Rice's numbers
approachable no no you got a thing then
he played 20 years but not only that but
he played with you know three the best
quarterbacks to ever play the game
universe cannon NFL MVP Joe Montana
obviously Hall of Famer steve young hall
of famers any played a couple years with
with jeff garcia who was a you know
multi-year pro ballplayer I mean that's
four guys that anybody would love to
play with many were there to play
without for him so you know he was many
couple that will be in this is the
greatest wrong
in history and having tremendous skill
set is a tough combination all right so
what you're saying is that if you had
played with those quarterbacks you'd
probably have 1500 catches no I'm back
oh ok ok i know that's me saying that if
you played with those guys you might
have you know but then you gotta take
into account you you gotta take into
account you know you got you have to
have great health you know it's it's a
lot of different combinations abila to
play that long to play at that high of a
level then he had some great players
around him I mean you got Ronnie lot on
your team Charles Haley you got Roger
Craig and and I'm even going on and down
down the line not the great players he
played with his well before I let you go
your dad ever written a mean thing about
you covering you know the other rich he
hasn't written anything mean but he just
tells it to my face you are son you were
absolutely horrible today I don't even
know who you don't even know who you
were I mean this is again I wanted to he
told me one thing you wanted he wanted
to smash the Fitzgerald off the back of
my dirty because it was it was an
embarrassment to the family not that
won't hurt a little bit I got over it
though and you're Pro Bowl wide receiver
imagine if you weren't and go with me to
a high standard high standard and
rightfully so great to talk to you and
enjoy what's left of the offseason there
thanks for joining us Thank You mr.
Patrick's always a pleasure talking to
you have a great day all right Larry
Fitzgerald mr. Patrick they're joining
us on behalf of EA Sports EAS sports
nutrition the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience